mesdames messieurs bonsoir plus de deux
mois après la catastrophe de tchernobyl
des traces de contamination radioactive
sont encore décelable aujourd'hui dans
plusieurs régions françaises et en
particulier en corse des traces légères
certes mais cette constatation contredit
la thèse officielle laquelle prétend que
tout est maintenant revenue à la normale
hélène risacher et jacqueline denis
l'empereur notre conscience de sciences
et vie ont accompagnés tout à l'heure un
petit garçon corse pour une visite
médicale au commissariat de l'énergie
atomique et bien pas de doute son
organisme recèle toujours des traces de
produits ionisants
dominique 10 ans et sa mère en rab rose
ont débarqué ce matin à orly il arrive
de valley qu'à un petit village des
montagnes corses une famille de fermiers
il ya quelques semaines après la
catastrophe de tchernobyl
on avait relevé en corse des tours de
5000 becquerels par litre de lait 10
fois supérieurs à la norme européenne
depuis on leur parlait plus des
conséquences du nuage radioactif de
tchernobyl mais madame antoniotti a
voulu en savoir plus
jamais se renseigner
et j'ai su que les légumes mon fromage
et tous étaient contaminés par ce nuage
donc je suis ici à
l'examen médical boss car mes enfants
ils mangent des produits de la ferme et
j'avais peur que leur ai pas eu quelques
désastre dominique et sa mère ont été
examinées pendant plus de deux heures
dans ses laboratoires du cea entrevue
quasiment clandestine pas de
journalistes déclaré ici quant aux
analyses elle montre que le jeune
dominic a été en contact avec des
produits radioactifs
et chez cet enfant on trouve encore de
nano furie
1931 et 17 même au curry de césium 137
alors qu'est ce que ça vaut mieux
important que parce qu'on trouve
actuellement évidemment chez le reste de
la population ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire que la corse a été
particulièrement touchée par le nuage de
tchernobyl et que les corses n'ont pas
été du tout informés de cette de cette
affaire comme le reste de la france
d'ailleurs ça je trouve vraiment une
phrase est même possible on a délaissé
desjardins millions est
aujourd'hui le danger passé reste la
colère compréhensible
le taux de radioactivité découvert dans
l'organisme du jeune dominique n'est pas
dangereux pour lui mais il est supérieur
à la normale deux mois après le passage
du nuage de tchernobyl
les radiations qui l'ont touché sont
faibles mais l'ong a éliminé quelques
précautions sont donc à prendre dans les
régions est et sud est de la france bien
laver ses légumes évitez de consommer
des fromages de chèvre frais en
attendant la disparition de toute trace
de radioactivité